für mich jemals mit sicherheit wissen
was andere meinen
sind ja nur hülle für das was mir vor
kein ausdruck was man effektiv
ausdrucken ich glaube das sind nur
gefühl oder
gesichter zeigen dass städtisches wieder
unterschiedlich je nachdem welche
kulturellen hintergrund man hat also
meine freundin zum beispiel die
italienerin hat spanien die drucke
gefühl viel extremer es als video
durchschnittsschweizer oder freude
herrscht dann ist das das höchste der
gefühle
das ist der beste vater begrüßen oder
also da
bleiben dann noch nicht ob das dann
tatsächlich freunde herrscht und wir
sind auch immer interpretationssache
jeder hat andere grenze wie wie der
gegenüber im garten kommunikation
das beispiel des aktuell meine büro in
washington hinter um eine große boote
bis twitter wird das auf die ganze welt
ganz anders aus
bagdad und der untersagt durch die
provokation einer woche ein wort ganz
ganz unterschiedlich interpretiert
werden müsste das glaube ich erst wenn
man miteinander wirklich interagiert und
wenn man merkt dass da endlich und wenn
man sieht was der mann spielt und darum
ist eigentlich safe r wort viel
wichtiger als loser auf wort
[Musik]